hi are you hungry  oh now I've got a nanner okay what here  I want you to have this I'm not homeless  I'm hip  who are some of your favorite musicians  well there's like I love miles David now  the question I like to ask myself is  what is the ass of the task squeaky  chair  can I see red ease  it can card me till I'm 30 Adam actually  it says here you're 33 that's the good  Chi um Domo be eight six one one got it  I'll call you on Thursday  you should probably put my name in your  phone I gotta put some other names into  I'll put yours in when I'm putting those  in starts with a Amy Amelia Amelia  ashley-amber I know why you guys pulled  me over clearly I'm not drunk I can walk  in a straight line my varsity basketball  coach said I had such good vision I  could be a basketball player or a jet  pilot whoa sir you failed the  breathalyzer tear what hands behind your  back what what I swear you have the  retro main cited I think you say can and  will be used into the court of law